-Our next guest is a very
talented actress you know from
shows such as "Ray Donovan"
and "Better Call Saul."
She stars in
"The Banshees of Inisherin,"
which is in select theaters now.
Let's take a look.
-What are you doing home?
-I knocked on
Colm's sonny lorry.
He was just sitting there.
-Sitting there doing what?
-Sitting there doing nothing,
smoking.
-Was he asleep?
-He was smoking, Siobhan.
How do you smoke
in your sleep, like?
-Have you been rowing?
-We haven't been rowing.
I don't think we've been rowing.
Have we been rowing?
Why wouldn't he
answer the door to me?
-Maybe he just doesn't
like you no more.
-Please welcome to the show
Kerry Condon, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Kerry, how are you?
-Hey, hi. I'm a bit nervous.
It's my first
talk show in America.
-Well, you're off to
a great start.
You fully got up to the chair,
and that's the hardest part.
-Yeah, I know.
I was worried about that.
Thank you.
-Yeah. Now it's a breeze.
From here on out, it's a breeze.
-Thank you.
-I'm a huge fan of yours.
I love this movie.
For those who don't know,
it's about a couple of friends
who break up.
It's a platonic-breakup film.
You play the sister of
Colin Farrell's character.
You've worked with Colin before.
-Yes.
-In a film called
"Intermission," I believe.
-Yes.
-Yeah. And, so, was it nice to
have a sort of reunion of sorts?
-It was.
I'd known him over the years,
like, you know,
seeing him at things and stuff
and texts and things like that.
So, it is, because when
someone's quite famous,
you know, I'm always a bit
nervous about imposing on them.
And, like, you know, people are
always coming up to them,
and I don't want to be
that person
who's always coming up to them.
So, I think if it
had been someone else,
it would have been a bit --
taking my time approaching him,
where it was easy
because I knew him for so long.
-He's a pretty approachable --
As far as a famous person goes,
I do find -- I think Colin's a
pretty approachable fella.
-Yeah, but, still, you don't
want to be annoying people.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah, that's true.
That's a good lesson here
for everyone here to take away.
[ Laughter ]
Now, this was shot on an island
off the coast of Ireland.
And, you know,
Brendan and Colin were here,
and they were talking about
the locals
and their varying levels
of excitement
of having a movie
filmed on their island.
Did you find that people
were excited to see
either you or Brendan or Colin?
-Well, no, the only people
who were excited
where I was living were
these two cute little boys,
who were, like,
really, really young.
And all of them
had cute little glasses.
And they knew Brendan from
"Paddington."
-Yeah.
-Oh, my God! It was so cute!
-And did they care about
Colin at all?
-Couldn't give a
[bleep] about Colin, yeah.
-Well, there you go.
Well, that will keep
him from getting, you know --
getting airs about him,
you know?
-Exactly. Yeah, yeah.
-You know, even in the clip,
we saw, I guess,
a little Shetland pony there.
-A little donkey.
-A little donkey, right.
Excuse me.
A correction that's made in the
film, as well, I should note.
-Yes.
-It didn't seem like you had
to do as much of the sort of
animal co-starring that
Colin had to do.
But did you find that you spent
a fair amount of time,
more than normal, with animals?
-Yeah, well,
I'm good with animals
because I've got
horses of my own, you know?
So I'd be good around them.
But Jenny, the little donkey --
she was very young,
and, so, she had a little friend
donkey with her all the time.
Yes! Called Rosie.
-So, is that because
when you're young on set,
there are rules,
like, the donkey union --
-Like a chaperone, yes.
And then Rosie
would come on the set
and be, like,
kind of an older presence.
And so Jenny
would kind of relax a bit more
when she could see Rosie.
So I really, like -- Yeah, it
made Rosie feel really special,
'cause I hate favoritism.
-Yeah.
-You know?
-And it can happen.
It can happen with animals
just as easy
as is it can
with the cast, yeah.
And it's very nice
to have someone
who's sort of familiar
with horses.
to notice which one's
getting the favoritism.
'Cause it seemed Colin
didn't enjoy the horses as much.
-He had to a scene --
He had to do loads of
horse-and-carrot stuff,
which is hard, now,
and I'm not good at that.
But, like, he knew I had horses,
so I suppose he was
a little maybe insecure.
doing the horse stuff.
But I always tried to leave him
alone when he was doing it
so he wouldn't be embarrassed
or anything.
But we did have one day when we
were quite close to a cliff,
and I think the horse was
getting a bit, by the end of it,
like, "I'm done.
I just am done with this.
I don't want to do it anymore."
And it was windy and all sorts.
And at the end of the take,
Colin said to the costume lady,
"Oh, can I have a change of
underpants, please?"
Because we nearly went into
the -- off the cliff, yeah.
-It is -- This movie takes
place, you know,
100 years ago or so.
But, yet, it feels
very modern in the themes.
And it's also very funny.
I know you've worked with
Martin over the years.
And, you know, he's written --
He obviously writes in
different eras.
But I do feel like
there's this very --
like, a DNA that goes
through all his writing,
where it's very easy to
listen to.
It's very funny.
It does seem very natural.
Was it fun to get to work with
a script like this?
-Yeah, because I always loved
his Irish stuff.
Like, I mean,
I was a little biased --
-Now, you're Irish, correct?
-Yes, of course.
-Yeah, okay.
-And I had done all
the Irish plays,
so they were, like,
what I liked about his stuff,
and I always felt like
they were very moving.
And when he'd done his movies,
I was thinking,
"Oh, people, like, they haven't
seen all his stuff,"
because the Irish stuff
was so great.
So when I read the script,
I remember thinking, "Oh, yes!
It's like one of your
Irish plays but a movie,
so everyone's going to see now
how great you are at that,
the dialogue of the Irish stuff.
-It's a wonderful cast
from top to bottom.
And, obviously, this was shot at
a time where people
weren't getting
to interact as much
because it was during COVID.
And it -- I can only imagine
how nice it must have been
to be amongst a group of actors
who were working on
something as special as this is.
-Yeah, I hate talking about
COVID, though.
-Yeah, we don't have to.
-I hate it. I'm so sick of it.
Isn't that terrible?
But it's like
I think I have PTSD.
I shouldn't say that,
'cause I don't really have PTSD.
But there's something about it.
I just, like --
I wish we just never --
Pretend it never happened.
-You know what?
Let's just pretend
it never happened, alright?
-Thank you.
-You're very welcome.
-If you ever see a photo of me
wearing a mask,
it's because I had a bad cold.
-Yay. Okay, okay.
-It was a cold.
It was nothing else.
You were on one of
my favorite shows,
which was "Better Call Saul."
And you came in,
but you had never seen
"Breaking Bad," correct?
-Yeah. God almighty.
I'll never live that down.
I saw it now, but I hadn't seen
it when I did my --
-That's okay.
-Yeah, because it was a prequel.
-Yeah.
-Like, in my defense,
it was a prequel.
So I was like, "Well,
I don't really need to know
what happens in the future."
-Yeah. In a weird way,
it would make the job
as an actor harder.
because your character shouldn't
know what the future is.
-Exactly.
-Yeah.
Look at me making up
excuses for you.
-Well, I know, for my laziness.
I know.
It wasn't laziness.
I think I didn't know what
the audition was for, I believe.
-Well, you shouldn't have to go
watch seven seasons of a show
before an audition.
-I mean, you know --
-Yeah, I do.
Now, by the way, I didn't even
get a call for the audition,
so who am I to say?
-Well, I did
watch it eventually,
and I'm glad
I didn't watch it before,
'cause I think I would
have been really nervous,
because it was so good
and it was so original.
And I think I
would have overthought it.
So I was kind of glad
I hadn't seen it.
-Well, I said it to everybody
who worked on
"Better Call Saul."
Like, another thing that
I couldn't believe worked,
but not only worked, but it was
exactly as good as the original.
So it was a really
cool thing to see.
It was great to see you in it.
But this film, you were so
wonderful in this film.
-Thanks a million.
-And I told Brendan and Colin
when they were here,
because they're two of
my favorite actors,
but when they
were in scenes with you,
you were just
running circles around them.
So thank you so much
for being here.
-Thanks a million.
Thank you so much.
-I really appreciate it.
Kerry Condon, everybody.
"The Banshees of Inisherin"
in select theaters now.
We'll be right back
with music from
Kurt Vile & the Violators.